gardé à l'étang rouge
delphine est venu accompagné de roger en
loge
ah oui
là je la découvre
ça à faire couler énormément d'encre
roger c'est le crayon de compagnons de
hockey oui s'appelle roger ici présentes
oui s'appelle roger et alors c'est un
prénom de jeunes c'est
ça reviendra à la main dedans donc elle
en a quinze ans que décidé voilà très
bien j'ai
tout le monde n'a pas la chance de
s'appeler libye l'ucm asie dernièrement
delphine vous êtes venu avec roger oui
tout à fait accompagnées de rejets dans
call of car son chéri que j'embrasse que
j'adore roger aurait fait une crise de
jalousie en expliquant je n'ai aucune
confiance en marc germain castano
guillaume genton l'équipe de tpm ps vrai
delphine
alors non alors c'était un genre c'est
le rêve de faire construire alors non
comme maintenant alors c'était avant les
vacances il est effectivement venu avec
moi ben non pas ça faisait longtemps
qu'ils n'étaient plus venus et ils
voulaient tous vous voir et c'est vrai
que du coup faire une petite mise au
point avec certaines personnes ça
pouvait être sympathique mais moi je
n'ai rien fait ouais ouais il a dit
qu'il n'a aucune confiance en moi ouais
franchement il a raison
je dois confirmer la crise conjugale et
ça a été assez chaud c'est vrai que
roger était à la fois meurtri amer et il
avait besoin d'experts qui avait pris
pour
le gars études avant les voitures audi
il n'a pas eu toutes les explications
oui je pense qu'il est parti un peu
rasséréné à tort mais assez bénigne
alors ça va mieux c'est vrai que ces
derniers ces dernières semaines on avait
un peu traverser une crise de couple non
vrai aussi c'est vrai que sur la tour et
du coup vu que c'était effectivement mon
anniv et que je vous ai demandé hier un
cadeau un voyage et que entre temps bas
vous m'avez pas encore envoyé des
billets eh ben j'ai pris l'initiative il
ya une heure de nous prendre de billet
pour partir en vacances donc je pars
dans une semaine non voilà où était
presque vous en avez rien à [ __ ] bah
du coup voilà c'est enfin vous comprenez
quoi ah mais attendez
c'est comme en boîte douce en
classe exceptionnelle c'est pour mon
c'est pour mes 30 ans
ce sera exceptionnel vous reviendrez
dans l'émission
considérez que votre votre bonne
participation à une chaussée sera
exceptionnel
on mettra avec la participation
d'experts
voilà pourquoi on n'y aurait pas souvent
qu'on voit quand même ses vacances à
aller